Hey youtuber's it's Charlie and there's a
lot more Batman vs Superman stuff happening
like Emily Blunt maybe being the new Catwoman,
there's some info about what LexCorp is going
to be like and Justice League.
If you're finding me for the first time I'm
going to be doing more movie videos this summer.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything. I
usually try to split the week between Marvel,
DC and Star Wars. But feel free to suggest
other movie stuff.
So Emily Blunt is literally killing it in
Edge of Tomorrow right now so I guess we shouldn't
be surprised that there's rumors about her
becoming the new Catwoman. She's had a long
history of almost being big comic book characters
like Black Widow and Christopher Nolan's Catwoman.
Here is a breakdown of the what's happening
and where the character fits into the movie.
What's true as of right now is that she is
meeting with Warner Brothers about the franchise,
because if she did become Catwoman she'd have
to sign up for all of the new movies. Justice
League and all. So she hasn't actually be
cast yet, she's just the biggest person they're
talking to about the part. Quick side note.
She has met with Marvel about a mystery project
too. Rumored to be Miss Marvel. She's like
one of those A-List actresses that gets considered
for big action effects movies like these.
There's really two parts to the Catwoman news.
First it was supposed to be a romantic interest
for Ben Affleck's Batman. But because they
upgraded the movie to a Justice League prequel
and started teasing more big characters, everyone
is thinking they've changed that small character
into a much larger part. Thus Catwoman.
In case you didn't know Emily Blunt was one
of the top picks for Christopher Nolan's Catwoman
but she lost the part to Anne Hathaway. Not
because she was bad or anything, Christopher
Nolan just thought his take on the character
was better served by Hathaway.
So when they shook everything up and combined
the Batman and Superman movie universes Emily
Blunt got kicked back into the system. Movies
add big characters like this all the time
and cut them
out at the last minute. So until you see Catwoman
on screen in the actual movie just take this
with a grain of salt.
But if you want to see what Emily Blunt looks
like when she's kicking ass, go see Edge of
Tomorrow this weekend. Catwoman is a totally
different character, but a lot of times it
helps when you see actors doing other big
action movies.
How is all this going to work when there are
already a billion characters in the movie?
Well I think they'll just be teasing a lot
of those big secondary characters out and
then giving them bigger parts when we get
to the actual Justice League movie and any
sequels after that. So yes there will be a
ton of big characters, but most of them you
won't see that often.
I really like her as an actress and I think
it kind of sucks she missed out on being Black
Widow and Catwoman but I like Scarlett Johansson
and Anne Hathaway too, so I wouldn't change
anything. But remember, if she gets cast in
the Justice League franchise, she probably
won't get to be Miss Marvel. So let me know
whether you'd like to see her as Catwoman
or Miss Marvel?
Based on a lot of the comments I think most
of you are more excited by the idea of a Miss
Marvel movie than anything else. But now let's
talk about Lex Luthor:
One of the biggest character changes in Batman
vs Superman is Jesse Eisenberg's Lex Luthor.
When they announced him for the role I feel
like everyone's brains just immediately went
to Social Network with capes. And some recent
production news kind of confirms that Lexcorp
will look a lot like Google and Facebook.
Like a really modern hipstery office with
super smart intimidating people.
They're supposed to be shooting a bunch of
Lexcorp scenes June 11th and 12th. So hopefully
we'll see a few pictures to confirm. I think
the biggest secret right now is whether or
not Lex Luthor is going to be bald. I'm not
expecting him to be just because I think it
would look bad. If you've seen any photoshop
edits of Jesse Eisenberg Bald, he does not
look better.
So just to talk about a big Justice League
rumor. Yes, Batman vs Superman stopped being
a Man of Steel sequel a long time ago. The
minute Warner Brothers decided to recast Batman
and put him in the film it because a Justice
League World's Finest movie. They're not saying
that officially, but when you add all of the
biggest Justice League characters together
it becomes a Justice League movie whether
you call it that or not.
The movie is intended to lead directly to
a Justice League team up movie. The title
is even Dawn of Justice, so think of it as
a prequel. I feel like the only big things
left to reveal are which Super Villain they're
going to use in addition to Lex Luthor and
when all of the Justice League members are
going to interact on screen at the same time.
I know a lot of you are asking about Stephen
Amell and Grant Gustin cameos. I definitely
don't think they'll be a part of Batman vs
Superman, but it's possible they could get
small cameos in Justice League. But personally
I think they're great just being on TV. I
don't think adding more characters to these
new movies will make them better.
Stephen Amell teased a potential Arrow Movie
once the series is over. I think there will
be at least 5 or 6 seasons, so that's a long
way away, but if you see the energy and enthusiasm
he has for the franchise I definitely think
he can last that long.
That's one of the best things about a lot
of the DC tv shows, the actors are so much
more engaged with us the audience than movie
stars are like Henry Cavill and Ben Affleck.
A lot of that is just because there's so much
secrecy. But TV is the god of social media.
I am really excited to see Stephen Amell and
Grant Gustin create like a mini Justice League
team on TV. I think you guys will all be really
happy with the way those shows work together
this fall. Unlike Batman and Superman, I consider
The Flash to me an official member of Team
Arrow. So it's much more of a partnership
from the start.
Batman from what I hear is going to be very
mistrustful of Superman for most of the new
movie.
Zack Snyder kind of killed the idea of Kryptonite
in the first Man of Steel movie, so I'm curious
to see how Batman deals with Superman the
first time they meet. They're not going to
be best buds. And in the comics, Batman's
Kryptonite Ring was his insurance policy against
a Superman freak out.
But let me know how you think Batman is going
to deal with Superman?
The only real weakness we saw in the first
movie is Kryptonian Atmosphere. That's the
only way to take his powers away. Unless Batman
got his hands on some Kryptonian tech before
most of it blew up or got sucked into the
Phantom Zone.
So in related news, I'm working on a new Doctor
Who video for tomorrow be sure to subscribe
to get it, new Walking Dead hopefully tomorrow
too and later tonight I'll post my Fault In
our stars review.
Right now click here to learn more about Badass
Emily Blunt in Edge of Tomorrow and click
here to learn more about Justice League.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!